my
auspicious remarks on an auspicious day
both the uh
the season and one of the songs
sets one in wu doesn't it
don't it always seem to go
when people lose their
inner authenticity you know sometimes we
want to shrink religion down into the
institutional religions but i think we
all know it's much bigger game than that
and manchester confusion thinker he
would talk about inner authenticity
when you lose that religion when you
lose that inner authenticity where you
go
you know you lose your pigs or your
chickens and your dog you go out on the
front and you call for them there's a
good chance they'll come
but you lose that
don't it always seem to go
that you don't know what you've got till
it's gone
and you lose that
and at your age well maybe some have a
sense of it but that as the years and
decades stick on
it's gone like a dog sometimes
gone like a really good friend
you think uh if you can hear me now
you need to give the report oh sure well
that's the best part it's all downhill
from here
so
the religion uh
losing that
uh ecology i guess that's where i'm at
at this point in my life i
i have seen uh along with mary evelyn
tucker some scenes that i wanted to show
you that set me on this career so let me
launch into it uh
i wanted to suggest by these terms of
field and force that what we're about
that this collaborative activity that
we're calling religion and ecology is
to establish an academic field so
here at yale we teach courses in
religion and ecology and have a joint
degree program between the divinity
school and forestry and environmental
studies
and also then the sense of force
this is an engaged project i think by
the end of it you get a sense of what i
mean both from these slides and then
from the short video piece afterwards
we're engaged scholars now we're we're
interested in the abstract to use that
term and i'd like to make maybe some
apology or defense of the abstract maybe
in the question and answer time
but we're also interested in the engaged
on the ground religious environmentalism
so this project has both of those types
of concerns often
our colleagues in the academic world
will say you've crossed the line
you've lost objectivity
you've given over to your own
subjectivity of engagement
our colleagues who are on the ground
working in projects say
grimm
you're too abstract
you're just an academic
so we're navigating along this kind of a
nice edge trying to do some work huh
maybe an overview of these remarks is uh
i'm trying to get at some of the
cultural values that
are shaped by uh world views
uh from the standpoint of uh i have
world religions here dom dot i wanted to
suggest not simply the institutional
traditions we can talk more about that
uh humanitarian and secular values the
sense of environmental ethics willis
jenkins up at the divinity school does
very fine courses in this regard
question of behavior with regard to the
natural world stephen kellert and ed
wilson at harvard had stephen keller
formerly at the forestry environmental
studies that paid a lot of attention to
biophilia and keller will talk about it
as gin we're genetically coded which i
find very interesting in terms of thomas
berry who i'll show in a bit uh
aesthetic in the arts so the type of uh
sensing and minding if i could use that
kind of language sensing minding that
leads to creating i think the arts gives
us some very good indications
of this kind of philosophical
and
aesthetic understanding
just a few slides and let me move
through them quickly it's more of a mood
that i want to create here these are put
in by mary evelyn tucker who in terms of
globalization uh
professor wolf is in china mary evelyn
is currently in india
she's
helping
push along a project that we have which
i'll talk about later and also at an
earth charter meeting
please and take a note
take a look at
earthcharter.org i believe i have it
wrong if it's dot com try both but the
earth chart is a very interesting
effort out of global ethics
with regard to these issues so it's
worth a look at and they're celebrating
25 years since this document was done at
ahmedabad in india
so
her whole impulse on this religion and
ecology project
comes from her studies in east asia
especially japan
and in that setting her encounter not
only with the
uh constructed natural world of the east
asian
confucian and buddhist traditions but
also the political
implications of confucianism which is
her field now it may seem strange that
i'm i'm moving over a number of
so-called religions or fields of very
quickly confucianism buddhism
uh and associating them with one person
but in fact in the east asian sphere
it was buddhism that carried
confucianism to japan
so these traditions interact much more
significantly and the ways in which they
have interacted with the natural world
influenced her so
she came to this project uh with that
1970s encounter in east asia and it was
uh gradually over the years then as we
lived in these settings and we returned
for her work to live for some
three years in japan
and we could see
this
change in the landscape in east asia
which is
so
evident today to people who come and
visit in those areas
the sense of
the air quality
uh it's remarkable to see the changes
that have happened in the last 30 years
and say bangkok huh
you think of where uh
seoul korea was when i first went to
study with ecstatic practitioners
healers called mudon women who are
shamanic practitioners and where seoul
was when i first visited and where it is
now recently
i mentioned healers because my primary
field and what brought me into these
studies in religion and ecology
is my work with the
north and um north american american
indian peoples uh
uh these uh crow absolutely people and
this is a family that i've worked with
uh most closely john cummins uh with the
glasses in the back is uh the older
gentleman i have one of these
uh is uh a what the crow call an akbali
a balia is a person an ak a suffix put
to indicate instrumental activity on the
part of that
which follows it's a person who can do
something
and as a healer and working with him for
30 years it's very interesting to
begin to enter into those cultural
understandings that crow people have to
their natural world and of course one of
the ceremonials that
i first went to study in 1979 and that
brought me into these understandings is
what outsiders call the sundance but
what the crow call ashke se liswa liswa
is to dance
and ashkeh is a difficult word to
translate big lodge
but its intention is imitation lodge
this is a lodge built to make present
the cosmos
so
neil's remarks earlier about
cosmological thinking in the religions
it's on the ground with these people
this lodge is only halfway through now
but you also notice this stuff buffalo
head and there's a stuffed eagle in the
rafters so there's an effort to bring
the presence of also biodiversity into
this cosmos it's not just human men and
women who will come in here and dance
and they dance for three four or five
days depending on the person who
sponsors it and they go without food or
water
and their effort is then to achieve
something they call diagashay
sincerity may authenticity
that inner something
that makes a person
but it's a person in relationship to
this
this place where the poles the
lodgepoles come from where the buffalo
come from they have a herd of 600
buffalo in a box canyon in the bighorn
mountains
where the eagles come from because the
dancers blow on eagle bone whistles when
they uh perform this ceremonial and this
whistling this constant whistling of the
men and women dancing will draw eagles
out of the mountains and they'll tell
gyre over this lodge so you're this
effort to achieve diagashay this
sincerity is in relationship to these
elements so here's a a religion then
that
has
has definite agendas with regard to
interior experience but it's also the
case
that indigenous people now
uh are making their mark
in the
world of resistance huh
through their religions or life way i
prefer that term rather than religion or
don't want to erase religion but i
prefer life way
because their religious activities are
not pulled apart from the world as they
know it the world of everyday activity
so native people would see this
resistance as having something to do
with their life way with their sincerity
with their authenticity with their
relationship with the world so this tar
sand
demonstration
by northern canadian peoples is in
league with say the undrip document the
united nations declaration on the rights
of indigenous people at which there were
only of the nations of the of the united
nations only four who refused to sign it
new zealand australia canada and the
united states and new zealand and
australia have reversed and have signed
uh canada has not nor is re it's not
considering changing its the united
states under this administration is uh
reflecting and calling back its decision
to rethink it huh so it's very
interesting to to feel the um the effect
of indigenous people and so many of
these issues so these this type of
background is what really brought me
into this religion and ecology project
along with a scholar named thomas berry
who taught mary evelyn myself i did my
dissertation with barry at fordham
university mary evelyn did a masters and
then went to colombia's
east asian and languages program to do
confucianism but
this guy's vision
uh
really uh articulated itself after he
was 60.
and he lived to be 94 and i think it was
this vision that carried him on he
really
all of these books that are mentioned
here were published after he was 60. he
has a whole set of works
prior to this on
his work as a historian of religion or a
cultural historian is a better term
his
understanding of these issues
comes from out of his concern
with regard to cosmology he was
interested in the cosmology of religions
that those religions he uh put his mind
to study and acquire some understanding
of it was their cosmology that
interested them their story of the of
reality as we know it
and so his focus then became on the
universe itself and his question became
where are we
as a species we humans on this planet
what's our story as a whole so the
globalization project was is very much
in the background of his work
because his concern was we have many
stories from the traditional communities
and they are still valorized they still
motivate as neal's point made
but we are also very much aware that
they don't motivate as they did in the
past
and so his uh concern was
we now have a
scientific story of our emergence
ah from
early
primal flaring forth
of
reality as we know it into the galaxies
and the solar system and life on earth
here
and the human community itself so that
became for him a new story
and it was that story that he felt
raised the question a new question for
us
that the universe as we know it uh is
has this subjectivity
so uh there's a
lot many questions that
draw for some closer philosophical
attention than barry himself could give
before he died but he left a legacy
which is very interesting for example
he has this um
observation that
this moment that we face is utterly
unique
and so that in itself marks
the difference of this moment for the
so-called world religions
it marks it also for the
non-believing community the new atheists
the
um community of
uh secular
political activity all of us experience
this moment in our own unique way and
for barry
one of these abiding questions would be
we have not even thought about this in
the world religions
we have a very clear ethical regards for
these issues if you cut yourself
or if you cut other people if you kill
other people even now genocide in the
20th century but these
concepts of ecocide or biocide or
geocite still perplexed the religious
tradition so
this project then
is
grows out of an awareness this religion
and ecology product project out of the
types of issues that we're
all all aware of in this class uh the
the sense of uh
uh urbanization and uh alienation from
the land in conjunction with the prior
issues
that
climate change and all of the global
issues that go with that and
biodiversity loss these probably
the two more prominent
global environmental issues that we're
aware of and as we see these species
wink out
it's an it's an issue
about this
you don't um
you don't know what you've got till it's
gone
and uh
it's enough to give a person agita
uh at some days and so neil's remark
about
environmental despair
is easy
but finding hope
these are people also that we find hope
with in terms of dialogue partners are
coming to forestry and environmental
studies was very important for us our
whole career has been in religious
studies so the divinity school is very
familiar religious studies is a very
familiar setting for us but forestry and
environmental studies these are the
people then that raise questions for us
which are very sharp provide information
for us which is ever changing but at
least probing in a contemporary mode
and gus beth has been quoted several
times and again just to re-emphasize
neil's point gus beth has said very
clearly
40 years of a career
establishing pro
the foremost environmental organizations
in the united states for monitoring
environmental health a career in the
united nations development program and
for him to say after 40 years knowing
that we have the science that we have
the legal laws quite often in the books
not only in this country but let's say
in china also in india also the laws are
on the books
but we do not have the motivation he
would say we have not turned the corner
on this and why not that's his question
why not where's the motivation so he's
now calling for greater participation
from the religions
from the
philosophical community from the arts
and so
our project in religion and ecology has
sought to really interact on the policy
side at the top and then on the religion
side on the bottom huh so that
our effort is to share
a common sense that
we feel we have in common common with
the
science community
cellular life has opened itself up in
ways that maybe for those of us who are
not scientists we we begin to understand
even the amazing character of
photosynthesis
and to think about
what it means to come to the symmetry of
growth in its larger expression even
ourselves and our movement through time
and the varieties of beings that we
share this planet with and the wonder
the incredible wonder that
all of this presents to us
and so these kinds of projects as i've
indicated before with thomas berry and
his
focus on cosmology have brought us to
one of the projects that i invite you
all to participate in march 25th
at the forestry and environmental
studies
we will show a new film which we've made
called journey of the universe it's an
effort by a mathematical cosmologist
brian swim to literally tell the story
of the emergent universe and i think
that character of story is something we
might talk about in the question and
answer so march 25th
the
religion and ecology project on the
religion side is significantly oriented
towards uh
assisting religions to move into their
ecological phase so that
these religious leaders the dalai lama
benedict the 16th um williams the
archbishop of canterbury uh has someone
help me what's his first name
thank you krone
and
the green patriarch not so many people
know bartholomew
the patriot ecumenical patriarch of
constantinople or istanbul a major a
spokesperson for religious
environmentalism i'll speak more of him
in just a moment
tiknot han many of you should know the
dharma master chengyan over 6 000
recycling centers in taiwan
she is a zen buddhist
leader in taiwan who's become very
active in global outreach so eco-justice
human justice tied to environment and
these other leaders obviously the the
sense of uh environmental justice
picturing wangari and mata is also a
major concern of this religion and
ecology project because this
issues of environmental pollution of
environmental problems due to climate
change affect people on the ground and
so the uh religious traditions not only
in their uh
uh beliefs and practice but also in
their on-the-ground activities so the
tsuji problem um
the tsuji sect was pictured there i
wanted to move into the area that neil
also mentioned that religions definitely
have to be considered in their
problematic character in this
context of religion and ecology also
we've had a recent occasion
in the election i think to see some of
these statements on the on the margins
also
with regard to climate change i received
a email today
outlining the statements by some of the
new members of the house with regard to
climate change and labeling it a hoax
labeling it simply a cyclical pattern
it's due to sunspots so we have a very
interesting connection here between the
political and the religious where
there's there's a mutual um
interaction there where the intolerance
and unwillingness to consider these
questions
marks some of the religions
also within the religions you find
transcendent orientations which
would tend to remove people from concern
for the material world so it's obviously
one of the problems in the religious
traditions
that's evident and
historical
issues where nature is devalued which
have resonated into the present for
example the
charge of paganism
which is used quite often in discussions
to simply
appropriate the ground
that any christian or any of the
abrahamic traditions especially anyone
from the abrahamic traditions who would
give attention to the natural world as
an integral reality uh sometimes might
be charged with paganism it's a kind of
nature devalued card i think the
anthropocentric focus i think is a major
concern saying the seminaries
where uh christian yeshivas
or
the
islamic teaching centers name escapes me
right now where the
anthropocentric focus is very clear the
traditions uh educating clergy
to meet challenges often in a human
earth context only
the promise of religion is also
very evident once one begins to consider
it namely
large numbers of people in institutional
authority as well as the possibility of
retrieval
from textual traditions from ritual
traditions from the commentarial
traditions
a new understanding of what these
traditions have actually said about
individuals and communities in
relationship to bioregions
so this is a very uh
very significant part of this religion
and ecology project and is actually part
of where we began this project
obviously one of the positive promises
of religion is the capacity to educate
and bring people into some sways of
encounter environmental ethics and
action the
roof here of the yale divinity school
prior to the building of the new croon
center for uh forestry this was the
largest solar array on campus and also
an evangelical college with a obvious
interest in uh crea in environmental
activity and notice the language issue
here how people finding their own
language to talk about these issues in
the religions
a text
slide which
rather than simply
repeating the slide i think it gives you
a sense of the range
of activities that we need to understand
and neil was going at the same thing
with regard to
ecological
positions or perspectives in the
religious traditions so that when i talk
about retrieving in the traditions
bringing forward the past i think these
are the areas in which to consider this
retrieval act but i don't think they
mean much unless we re-evaluate what is
retrieved
so does it have anything to say to the
present if it does if a tradition's past
speaks to contemporary issues then i
think it calls also for reconstruction
of tradition so retrieval reevaluation
and reconstruction are major agendas of
this religion and ecology project and of
the three reconstruction is obviously
the most difficult religions are very
conservative slow to change and to so to
consider reconstructing themselves is
very difficult
i want to move through these very
quickly i think in the readings you got
a sense of the project that we had done
it
uh after 10 conferences it culminated
with several conferences in new york and
the formation of the forum on religion
and ecology which we've brought to yale
and the publication of these volumes
over 800 scholars have collaborated in
the initial beginnings of this project
and brought these books which are still
very fine resource works in this field
we have a
journal now which is a peer-reviewed
journal it's
it's 12 years old now and it's a setting
in which younger scholars can place
their published works so this is very
important and we'll watch a piece of the
renewal film which is again our first
entry into film projects to bring larger
communities into consideration of these
issues
some of the activities that we continue
to be involved in
along with the daedalus
publication some years ago is to support
this attention to climate change in
various settings and i just want to
point out the indigenous environmental
network the attention of indigenous
people to climate change is rather
remarkable the evidence and the
statistical the empirical evidence which
is being reported by indigenous peoples
and is being recorded by such a group as
the indigenous environmental network is
is substantial and uh as i want to
indicate very important
uh and on the ground group interfaith
power and light is worth mentioning
largely in the christian jewish islamic
communities in the u.s but very
focused on church audits
on the whole idea of energy use by
religious institutions another project
that we began uh quite early after the
initial conferences on the religions was
to raise the question of religion and
animals and this continues uh this work
at the yale center for bioethics where
we have our offices so the
religion and animals group also at the
american academy of religion where i
just came from and also neil was there
we i had a chance to chat a bit
that the professional organization of
all religious teachers in the united
states and canada have significant
groups on animals and also religion and
ecology
i mentioned
the animal issue because many of you
might know the earth mass that saint
john the divine held every october at
the feast of saint francis of assisi
where they open the main doors i think
you should be aware it's only when the
bishop comes and knocks on the door that
they open the main doors at saint john
the divine but at the earth mass they
open them for the animals and they bring
these animals right down the front the
aisle the central aisle and people bring
their dogs and cats you can see in the
background it's remarkable to sit in the
pews with parakeets chickens dogs and
whatnot and not the place doesn't go
into absolute mayhem it's a very
interesting kind of moment
the music is especially remarkable paul
winter who many of you might know has
done the music for
probably
it's it's 15 years old now the earth
mass has changed on the dawn
uh religion and water is where i'm
heading to close up are we still okay
that's good um
the uh
religion science and environment
symposium where i'll go with the slide
in just a moment the friends of the
earth is a project which was nurtured
also here at yale at the world fellow
center and some
students graduate students at yale are
working on this project to bring the
abrahamic faith together on a project to
clean and refurbish the jordan river
many of the same issues with the yamana
so i'll save them for just a moment but
i did want to give some attention to the
ecumenical patriarch he has held eight
conferences focused on water
beginning with e.g in 1995 and through
the mississippi river next year will be
lake victoria in africa
his um his intention is to focus on
environmental issues so he gathers
together on a single boat over 200
politicians scientists
academics journalists people who are
focused on environmental activities and
rather than sailing to the significant
tourist spots
he goes to these troubled environmental
spots and the news articles that are
generated out of that by the new york
times
manchester guardian there's significant
news attention
uh to these environmental spots many of
which are are easily passed over by the
press
so the patriarch is one of these uh
religious leaders who has um
major thinkers like a metropolitan john
ziz uh who's helping him think through a
lot of these issues in terms of his own
theological tradition
and bartholomew this uh ecumenical
patriarch
has labeled uh
industrial pollution as a sin
so he's
someone who's tried to find language to
talk about these issues rather than
simply abstract orthodox statements he's
put himself in some
jeopardy within his own tradition for
example
on the amazon he allowed indigenous
leaders after he had apologized to them
on behalf of western civilization and
what it had imposed on indigenous people
and a personal apology from his
standpoint
he allowed indigenous leaders to bless
him and together they bless the amazon
river you can imagine what a leader like
this would pay in his own tradition in
terms of
collegial support for allowing other
religious leaders to bless him so he's a
remarkable
ecumenical and inter-religious
dialogue-oriented person uh the one case
study just a few close minutes on this
is coming up in january and
as i mentioned mary evelyn is helping to
in delhi now helping to get some of our
logistics clarified uh we're bringing
together
a yale terry so terry university in
delhi
but what's interesting here is the
joining of this discussion on the yamana
river by religious leaders from the
vrndavan area led by the radharaman
temple
religious leaders from vrndavan leaders
of significant pilgrimage sites this is
the setting
for a vaishnava theology namely where
krishna consciousness
emerged
in india over the centuries and i i mean
by that the uh ancient tradition of
krishna awareness
mentioned in the bhaga in the
mahabharata and the bhagavad-gita and in
later texts so
these religious leaders will come to
terry university on
january 3rd and 4th and we'll we will
have a dialogue on the condition of the
yamuna river the vrndavan temples are
all located on the yamana river the
yumna river is a goddess
so this is an effort to really pay
attention to what has happened to this
river and the paradox of religious
attitudes towards this river so the
yamana as you can see in turquoise here
parallels the ganga or ganges river
these two major sacred rivers in
northern india
and the yamana when it comes out of the
glacier
at yamanotri and develops into a
magnificent
river and it's especially first hundred
miles it's about a 900 mile long river
before it joins the ganges it is
actually larger than the ganges when it
joins it at alahabad
but the looks uh are subject to an
incredible assault
about 100 miles from delhi
this literal this river is literally
broken in half
and it's the two halves are channeled
into two canals
which are uh
directed towards irrigation of the green
revolution crops in the doha the region
between the yamana and the
ganges river so this is incredible
fertile agricultural region which is now
water dependent and the yamana is used
totally
to irrigate
those crops what returns to the yamada
then is laced with
agricultural runoff pesticides
insecticides fertilizers
then that water
is then dammed at the entrance to delhi
and that becomes deli drinking water and
the yamana is largely dry through delhi
except for industrial waste
and human waste so there is flowage
through delhi but it is eutrophic
and so beyond a delhi
the yamuna is largely uh eutrophic it
will not support
uh overt life there is aquatic life and
that's uh a miracle in itself
that there is still some life in the
yemen of beyond delhi
but this raises then
one of the paradoxes and i'm moving to a
close
namely
the issue of purity and pollution
that the
yamana
is as pictured on the bottom here is one
of the beloved of krishna
like the gopi maidens the herder of the
the cattle who are
from low caste so the social justice
issue is also very interesting uh in the
vaishnava theological tradition by what
i mean by that it's not simply a
brahmanical
focused religion where
this tradition and the person of krishna
himself he becomes blue by absorbing the
toxic
poisons that had been put in the yamuna
river so you can see the retrieval
characteristic of old ideas in this
tradition about toxins or poisons in the
river
krishna
is in relationship to the gopi maidens
and to the river in an ecstatic relation
of love
it's a tradition of it's a bhakti
tradition a tradition of deep devotion
so we have of course this incredible
paradox again where
even religious activity
is undertaken which seemingly wantonly
throws
um garbage from the ceremonials
themselves into the yamuna river and the
yamuna here is a deeply polluted river
so the conference is an effort to call
this paradox into question how could a
deified reality become so terribly
defiled
the
overarching agenda then in this religion
and ecology project is to activate
within the religious traditions in all
of their difference so this is not
simply a monological position but rather
extreme diversity in the traditions of
with regard to reverence and respect
then for biodiversity in a sense of
restraint which neil also mentioned the
ascetic
impulses within these religious
traditions now being seen in a broader
range on the question the uh social
justice question of distribution
of environmental technology and aid
to assist
other peoples and countries
to address their environmental issues as
an act of responsibility
more than in simply an anthropocentric
setting but in an anthropocosmic
understanding that we recognize
ourselves as part of this reality that
we live among and that this reality also
shares with us this larger story of the
emergence we share with all of reality
this sense of
living
on a planet which is itself alive
and
how to understand the restoration
project is obviously
one of the most challenging issues
because it immediately begs restore to
what and so that's a question i think
that we all ask ourselves
what is it
that we suddenly recognize
it's gone
and
having recognized it's gone we realized
that in some linguistic traditions gone
is a temporal
verbal
gone is something which people
understand as coming towards them
and gone is something which people
realize they're entering into
and gone is something which people see
happening
and having happened they realize it's
gone we don't have that kind of language
reflection in english so much but i
think we're capable of it and
restoration i think activates this kind
of thinking what is it that we restore
to is it something past
is it something present or is it
something to which uh
we want uh life
and ourselves to head towards i hope
thank you